[Music]
don't you be the hero the guy he's still
a work in progress
[Music]
the waistband Maria here in mine
No
[Music]
[Music]
the speeding waistband
[Music]
[Music]
your fingers Wow is super dumb if their
egos in a dashiki
[Music]
bad guys boil themselves every time they
hear
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
here let me help you're welcome
[Music]
[Music]
hang on psychics
[Music]
what is happening right now I don't know
let's try and leave and see what happens
Wow
what's an expensive door mm-hmm from the
studio that brought you Shrek Kung Fu
Panda and Madagascar hi I'm Jorge beer I
miss my best friend Harold hutches we
just make comics and try to make each
other laugh and this old guy is mr. crup
George
he's the worst principal in the world
ever since you've attended the school
you've been responsible for one prank
after another some of those must've been
really hard to pull off
like that tiger oh that Tiger was crazy
ah I told you I would get you one day
I'm going to have you to place its SAP
rigs glasses we're going to annihilate
the friendship don't you do something
put the ping down mr. truck a wheel
hypnotize you
I snap my fingers you will obey our
every command whoa
I don't even think that what happened
this summer come sidekick we gotta stop
him haha why thank you vehicle person oh
yeah
what's Robbie you'll get him their
greatest creation Captain Underpants you
can't actually fly I take to the sky
like an awesome wow he is super dumb
timid ease now their biggest problem dad
ow
[Music]
based on the worldwide phenomenon hiya
Claire I'm your new teacher not some
scary guy with a secret evil agenda guys
I totally got this yeah totally he's got
it
Kevin Hart Ed Helms Thomas Middleditch
knit crawl
when it's cut all together like that you
really get a sense of the scope
DreamWorks
Captain Underpants pour so you're
trapped in some sort of invisible box
like prison is it okay that I'm kind of
loving this yep enough I will said you
breathe
oh but Mosley yet
[Music]